oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the stream this is
the arrow gods challenge but before we
get started I am putting hair gel inside
of socks because I hate myself and I
have to put these on and then wear Crocs
do you want me to hold it open for you
you know I you know I just want to
suffer through this bond my own can you
go grab my Crocs though those are really
what I'm by yes hoping for ox ah that's
more gel than I put in my head so we are
raising money for Save the Children
which is a great organization and even
though we are foolish but we're almost
at ninety thousand dollars raised which
is absolutely incredible
give you give yourselves a round of
applause for that thank you everybody's
contributed so far this is gonna be
awful that I'm about to do this yes very
good is it coming out of the song no
it's not it's very well contained oh
very good
I can't describe the sensation of what's
happening inside of my sock just squishy
come to mind Oh more than squishy Oh Gel
gonna heat up and just like keep them in
a constant state of oh I don't think
that's what's gonna happen
usually when gel is associated see me
through the sock at all oh it's very
water tight oh nice that's how you know
you got a good sock when you can put a
bunch of gel on it and none comes out oh
good socks all right so we're raising
money for Save the Children I'm doing
this because as part of our punishment
board which only gets picked when we hit
monetary amounts which if I'm not
mistaken we just hit 90 thousand which
means that someone else has to Bob for a
punishment and then we're gonna get the
arrow dodged whose turn is it
I'll go all right why did you sigh I
don't know if you want to I don't know
just go and I felt like sorry hold these
okay very important hey these are mine I
won't put it back on though I felt like
Ponyboy let me be party boy
boy yeah what please pony pony boy
Curtis what yeah
what okay we'll talk about this in a
minute let me Bob okay feel around with
him nose use that schnoz look it and
bite yeah get it get it you got it
can't grab anything why don't you push
it against the side wall you gotta be
suction he's a lot of suck and I've had
that good sup dude we cleaned out the
water by the way so this is clean fresh
water new not any element of that
horrible that was happening before all
that was so gross it was pretty bad I
was gonna that's going through my toes
oh I can't explain how weird this feels
because on camera it doesn't translate
because it's just what I'm wearing have
you ever had a pedicure no because the
only way I would have predicted to have
well how about let me say how it feels
cuz I'm feeling it right now what I'm
saying okay I can't really explain it
because it doesn't translate on camera
very well because obviously it just
looks like I'm wearing Crocs it looks
like have you ever been in a bathtub
full of mashed potatoes because I have
so imagine you're in a bathtub full of
mashed potatoes and you feel the
potatoes going through your toes and
whatnot are you done yet I think that
might be a better strategy from drink
all the water yeah by the rat bite it
just ate it whoa there we go finally
what do you got oh 10 ah no talking you
walk you can't talk the entire until the
next punishment if you want to talk you
have to go in the other room and talk
through either your phone or a
walkie-talkie I forget which one we have
all right is it those work these are the
ones but almost no maybe the battery I
think maybe all right you got your phone
yeah I got my phone so we're just gonna
have a phone call going and you just
want to telephone it's right behind you
or should be behind I think thank you
thank you very much all right I'm
calling you okay do we want to FaceTime
we're doing I'm just normal call call
okay all right you got to put your phone
in the other room sorry I do not disturb
on okay hello hello hey how's it going
doing pretty good how are you good yeah
put your phone in the bathroom or
something before about yeah yeah the far
bathroom yep okay all right so Ethan
can't talk until yeah Ethan can only
talk by running and going over there if
he wants to say anything all right cool
all right all right all right all right
okay so here's how it's gonna work we're
gonna be dodging arrows new mute
wait it's working now mute yeah I can't
hear you on the other end
no that's not the problem I got it okay
all right
so we're gonna be doing this and we're
gonna be dodging arrows shot by the
wonderful Tyler over there just to give
an example of the power that we're
dealing with you might want to move ah
[Music]
sound effects are okay so that's what we
got to deal with but it's never that
simple
oh go get the duct tape stupid goof you
big bag of boom that's wrong I don't
know where the duct tape is where is it
duct tape it's right here you idiot get
back over here I can't hear you because
you're muted idiot
it's weird you know I told you you're a
ninny
did you just assume you're an idiot ha
obviously here it is you big goof yeah
that's what I thought ok so we've got a
excuse we got a Twitter works excuse you
we got a twist we we got a twister man
so with this twister match what we're
what we're gonna do is we're gonna take
the right hand left foot left hand right
foot thing and instead of us actually
doing twister like normal people we're
going to tie those things together that
can include me no it's just gonna be
even an eye because we're the only ones
capable of dodging right now
Tyler's knee is still bad you can't make
sudden movements so we're gonna do this
okay who wants to go first I don't care
what those breakers what okay you could
have pointed at me or something we could
put we'll play rock-paper-scissors okay
rock-paper-scissors
okay so on three like
rock-paper-scissors shoot right yeah on
shoes okay I'll be back in a sec okay
idiot hey I love you nope don't forget
the safety goggles let's do it
alright okay so I'm gonna go this BAM
right but
right okay so that means I have to yes
please then thank you oh god I have to
try to dodge oh no oh no with my right
foot tied to my right hand very kind of
you to not want to destroy my pants I
got it thank you
alright so while we're getting set up
here remember there's a tilt to fight
link down in the description below we've
been making great progress throughout
the stream we've been beating the
average to like the duration of time
that we need to go for and how long the
string goes how much money we need to
race with 19,000 raise we're almost
halfway there but this is the fourth tub
eighth challenge we need to push beyond
that we need to number one get to the
halfway point by the end of this but
also we have to push past this so please
if you haven't made a donation yet and
you still can please do because
everything that you do is gonna be
double this entire time so please make a
donation what
yes hey you should be good to go I don't
take your hands to your feet okay thank
you welcome okay chica chica all right
so please consider making a donation
please consider sharing the donation
link ask your friends and family to make
a donation to this because we've got a
long way to go and we're ready to stand
in the line of fire for this but we need
your help all right okay you can protect
me come on I can't stand in the line of
fire
more like crowds in the line of fire am
I
right delayed Joe what'd you say I said
I said I said stand in the line of fire
cuz that's what you said and then I said
more like crouched in the line of fire
but it's not as funny cuz it's a little
bit of a delayed joke now okay all right
I'm gonna dodge an arrow okay all right
but I'm gonna come back so tell Tyler
not to shoot me all right Tyler don't
shoot him okay all right all right
somebody chica what's wrong what I trust
your accuracy ha ha no I don't like this
Jail advice jocks all right keep going I
don't like this
how many shots doing good I don't know
three and then what we're okay
nice Dodge thank you oops I got other
ones all right all right I've got an
arsenal okay all right okay I got hit
two times I got hit two times you goof
it's your turn to go okay uh I'll just
leave that there in case I need to get
it back in there I'm gonna watch him so
I know this is accurate left foot left
foot right hand left foot right hand
okay got it
come back the door behind you
left foot right
okay while they're there taping Ethan's
left foot to his right hand you can
donate to make us have to do another
punishment and be forced to do that
punishment during this event you know I
am gonna take a punishment just because
I can't dodge at the end of this so
donate now a thousand dollars you get
written on us and it's important because
everything you do is doubled so share
like and get people here to donate that
can donate even if you can't everything
that's worth double just because our
goal is doubled the stakes are doubled
and we have AIDS
anonymous donor that is gonna match
every donation up to two hundred
thousand dollars which means if we meet
our goal we will have raised $400,000
for Save the Children and now I'm going
to shoot Ethan who can't talk huh oh my
protection
I guess that's relatively important
gotta keep those glasses on maintain the
the pony man that's monkey-talk I think
that counts what's that a Dodge chica
good job keep your good job Billy down
pub go lay down - good wait hey wait go
lay down flip up lay down stay safe stay
low okay you've got he got two out of
three hit two three hit are yes sir
we're still tied up alright I got go
again toss me some arrows I'll get them
because he didn't decide and I wanted to
take this offer to actually Busan oh you
can take it off for now
I think that's acceptable okay
[Laughter]
all right so my answer I told you Etha
shut the door
gosh right hand if you get the same one
does that mean you're free no right foot
again all right I can do that all right
well don't take it off what if you get
it again coming look at yes put that on
my face please thank you all right
looking good
okay all right okay you've had practice
with this one so I'm not holding back
why would your home Mac I love that
sound when it does hit the door though
my anticipation of jump why are you
running at him huh instead of talking
did I break your mouth
so while they're affronting you can
donate it help us meet our goal and
exceed our goal because we reach
$200,000 nan miss oh dear whoa match
that amount and we'll get 400,000 share
hit that Bell buzzer you're notified
when we are live keep donating because
then we have more punishments to do
everything is worth double this stream
and it's all for Save the Children which
is an excellent charity the money goes
towards their education protecting them
from harm and keeping them healthy so it
is extremely important charity that they
work in crisis times and in 120
countries all the time nice and seasoned
are you ready Oh
decisive strike oh I have an idea I have
an idea okay I have an idea first I want
to vote to let Ethan talk cuz it's
awfully difficult this way yes yeah okay
yes
how does let you talk for now okay I
have an idea because I'm gonna change
things on the fly as we're going what
donation level are we at we're at ninety
two thousand six hundred and eighty
seven so we got a long way to go it's
only 247 right now which means that we
got a lot of time left in this stream
and we got a lot of time left in this
game
I say we mix it up and tie one of my
arms to your all right I'm down and down
okay
and then we both have to dodge that's
right going on over here
all right ready ho okay so this will be
you or me this will be me okay so your
left hand to my right hand thank you
that's so sweet
is it wait we're just like this am I
trying to shoot you're trying to shoot
both of us your right hand you idiot so
you're both trying to dodge while you
guys are connected so wherever you hit
that's important here safety mr. haire
you can still be rambo boy okay how do
you not know what outsiders is you were
never forced to read that what I know
it's a great book I can't remember
[Laughter]
goodbye elbow I think
whoa my other heart I don't have to do
anything if he says gaming three
might've just straight-up hit the mic
one more and then we'll switch body
parts
oh one more are you guys keeping track
of me maybe
yeah the drive here chica oh sorry I
wasn't keeping track of the score what
do we got
I hate you both with one of them and I
hit Ethan at least three times so that
would be four I only took five shots so
you got hit twice even got hit four
times that's because you both got hit by
one okay sure
you guys know what outsiders is right
what's outsiders it's right where people
are outside looking in you guys know
outsiders you don't know Ponyboy Curtis
it was Ponyboy okay in the stream
everybody please I observe golden
Ponyboy
how does nobody know this is this
something boy what is this
alright anyway it's fine my left foot I
thought it was the thing that was just
to your left hand my left foot your left
foot to my left hands yeah oh jeez
okay worried about you stepping on his
hand now though Lucius your face you
worry about holding us to death alright
you know yo all right what if I was
blind for this doesn't have to be like
this now I give his hand take this oh
wait my left hand yeah to my left foot
okay you got a pic what's up here oh
wait I know what to do
put it there I'm just worried I'm gonna
wrap it twice
wait wait wait no wait I don't like this
nope you're all set okay all set your
feet are so I get I have gel in my hands
now I am gonna break your wrist off
that's what you get for trying to learn
that was just a fist all right God how
many did you get
durbar move this way maybe he won't be
able to see us and my oh no you okay
yeah it's fine I just have a fracture
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
how do I hit darling very dead
[Laughter]
you don't know that don't praise oh
alright does chaos incarnate but before
we get to Kansas entired here once again
I want to thank you everybody so much
for joining but once again this stream
is all about you guys the stream is
everything driven by you guys we're
having a ton of fun here they've got a
lot more stuff to do but really honestly
and truly we are far from our goal
because as this stream goes on we all
know that like people go to bed people
don't like everyone tries to donate as
much as they can in the beginning and
then we have so far left to go and I'm
not saying like we need to reach this
threshold because of our own pride we
need to reach this threshold because
$200,000 means that we can do the
absolute most good because it's being
matched that 200,000 that we're looking
for is actually $400,000 if you've never
given to a charity before please take
the time to do it now because now more
than ever it's gonna make the most
difference because it's guaranteed to be
double what that impact is and if you've
already donated and you've already
shared once do it again sometimes it
takes multiple multiple attempts to
convince one person that like okay
alright I know this is annoying but then
they'll realize that it's for a good
cause I don't want you two guys to spam
the Internet but to be perfectly honest
spam the internet like it's it's
super-important for this one cause this
isn't from my benefit this isn't for our
benefit here this is for the children's
benefit this the the charity that we're
raising money for is literally called
Save the Children and it's such an
important charity because how many
people it affects it's 187 million
children just last year helping them
with health care education living
expenses just generally life improvement
even in crisis situations all of those
things exactly even in developed
countries so as much fun as we have here
it's so important that we help out and
contribute to this and I've even donated
money myself I've donated $10,000 I was
matching again what was already being
matched but I'm tapped out at this point
I will try to give more but I need you
guys to help out please dig deep please
consider donating please consider taking
the time to do so now even if you're
watching in this in the future when the
livestream is already off please
consider making a donation it will do
the world of good please consider
sharing again it will again do a world
of good
spread the word don't be afraid of being
annoying because you're being annoying
for a great cause and we also we have
that large overarching goal but you see
that package in one of these top corners
I believe it's this one that is 50
dollars that fifty dollars gives it's
like four thousand babies they get their
life-saving vaccinations they get their
prenatal and natal like vitamins and
nourishment and then they also get their
doctor checkup after they're born to
make sure that like they're well taken
care of and they have the best
possibility to survive just that $50.00
every single one every single time that
fills up that is four thousand babies
that are helped by Save the Children
yeah and it doesn't take that much to
get that package full what is it 1500
$50 it's $50 to get that package to go
up that's why there's 4,000 packages
there it's just $50 and we actively
encourage everyone possible to give
whatever you can we we're only doing
monetary donations we had shirts that
were there as a reward for donating but
they're gone they're all gone so it's
purely driven by selflessness and giving
and yes we're being annoying to you
right now but that's because I really
don't care when it comes to like a
concept as oh yeah like it's such an
important like momentous occasion like
it's it's a moment that's bigger
and me like it's it's just something
that stresses beyond what we do here so
please take the time and do it now click
the link in the description below share
the donation link tilt the five.com
slash at markiplier it will do a world
of good
and again like this is all we couldn't
do any of this without you guys you know
this is not to not to put it all on you
guys but it is all a community effort
like it's not just us raising this money
it's all of you guys we cannot do it
without your help and again today it's
more important than any other stream
that we've done because we have someone
matching all the way up to two hundred
thousand dollars and I think I speak for
everybody here that like you know we're
we are very very lucky to live the lives
that we live and like I had a very good
childhood and others around the world
are not so lucky and we're we're very
lucky and it's really important to help
out those in need and especially when we
have the chance to raise so much money
for hundred thousand dollars we have a
chance to raise today and that that can
go to help so many people worldwide so
it's really really important again to
everybody who's thinking of sharing the
stream you know tell people that there
is a match going on and that they're
donated that their donation is worth
double so if you really like one dollar
can go a long long ways and you know if
you're worried about being annoying on
social media and stuff about it like
keep posting about the stream nobody can
call you out for posting about charity
you know like it's all for a good cause
so please don't be afraid to share the
stream donate if you can because again
it's for a really really good really
good cause and we've raised a lot of
money so far but we have a long way to
go and like we've done it before and we
can do it again and we can hit the goal
but we need your help to do so so please
if you have a dollar if you have ten
dollars if you can spare any money at
all please donate it goes to help such
such a great cause and children and the
world and more about the charity for one
like we live a really good life and for
a lot of reasons in u.s.
one in five children in the United
States statistic don't like getting the
right amount of food there they go
hungry and Save the Children works in
120 different countries so all across
the world like if the US has one in five
I can't imagine where it is in other
places around the world
and your impact this impact could be
tremendous and huge and we want to
maximize what we can do especially with
that matching donor sharpy I think it's
right behind you
don't nevermind sharp shot here's
another shirt how about we do another
color who's getting written on I've got
my boy ready
all right leggy you want to go to this
leg that still hasn't named let's do
this leg all right this will be more
permanent than the last one here will
write at the same time
you and blue me in red okay we're both
writing with an A you all right wait
here I'm writing two of the same name
yeah baby
jeez Lauren we love you don't you try
unite your heart
okay I was giving you that sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
boy are you and I'm not sorry cannot
sleep I cannot dream tonight I need you
Lauren and always your name is on Tyler
permanent ink he can't wash off in the
shower not just one but two times and
all the spiders hunting every time okay
there we go I want to do something else
tie both of my hands to my ankles the
other one you can do is the crab walk
you could be reverse of that oh wait oh
yeah yeah that's right
times both my hands my angles both of
your hands tearing oh no yeah that one's
I'm gonna okay you're just gonna shoot
me okay I realize that this is actually
a very explosive you gotta commit do you
want to make that wider for your hand or
no yeah good
go for it it's all good it's all good
all right so as you guys donate as you
guys could possibly donate give whatever
you can okay
oh there one oh no it's already there
who's in all right okay all right oh
this is oh okay yeah okay that's pretty
important okay no mobility Co you want
to give away the yellows about to poke
me in the god mark move slightly to the
right I'm gonna try and shoot around you
haha frame you with the song I got it
I'll dodge it ah my face it's either
your face irritated Oh God this is very
much exposed crotch ah
no all right bring it up oh okay from my
angle it went straight right here oh I
think so
Thank You Elijah for being such a I hang
on wait I'm gonna put out ah I'm gonna
put make good was the name what do you
want lies I say yes you do it fingers no
no see I'm putting my say I'm gonna
putting my arms together right across
both you know no Tyler okay sure pieces
but I'm not like that
why
but II know IJ do it then I was I
pictured a difference I mean should I do
it still just you do seer just do some
knots ruined put elijah there you're the
greatest thing that ever happened to
today I think you're a ray of sunshine
on a cloudy day
I run day with David I don't I have a
lot of heart filled lock my eyes on this
John we race what time is it right now
we raised $100,000 in three hours and 35
minutes of total on screen time that is
yet unbelievably amazing thank you guys
so much for being so incredibly generous
Thank You Elijah you are amazing and
everybody that has donated so far but we
have still a long way to go so hopefully
they're we're halfway there everything
that we've done up until this point
that's what we have to do
why would I would I will die all right I
mean I have it to Bob because I don't do
you on the cookies on what I know I
thought I was gonna Bob cuz I had to
shoot no no I'm bobbing okay okay I got
a mom after you Bob cuz I my eyes are
closed I gotta stir it with me wha ah
good opportunity good job fair expensive
audio equipment that everything look
great go ahead it's a good bub whenever
you're ready sir that's gonna comical
isn't it didn't get moved in here yes
need help sir you want me to cut you
loose
[Music]
why a and I'm not sure did I cut it new
hmm why are you not talking I cannot get
this off thank oh I'm gonna go get Kyle
take it I'll take one Hey mm-hmm meh meh
meh meh almost there yes I forgot for
Kosta or doing now you don't know the
struggle here give me those ma give me
those sharp voice oh we should end the
call that we have going between the two
of us I already ended it you have
something to say mark the host lives
mm-hmm I got a bob I thought even was
Tenten wait that means I have one two
three four five yeah we need to do two
more I'll be tatted come here I mean
gotten tatted and you wanted sick ankle
Oh
Oh
Oh
Oh which one are we doing why a and I
yes okay give me one of those why am i
yeah
oh why use in red okay Yanni yeah I mean
that's what bark says that's it
wait he's he's gonna continue I got
another one okay Yanni we love you
alright let's get let's get a good heart
harmony harmony harmony you wanna you
want to get lower or you wanna go high
I'll go high Johnny thank you for the
donation
Oh Andrew Babcock oh hey you should rap
about it
Oh rap yeah get a good rap back oh yeah
I'll drop the beat for all wait am i
rapping
I thought mark was typing the rat
Babcock you the man with a plan
and nobody can stop yours real there
ain't no way anyone do not rapping or
just win
stick your flow Babcock youth man with
the plan and nobody puts down a bumble
oh another tattoo
yes wait where's the where did I put
them I've got the red one and the black
one we need to we need this one right do
you wanna do you want another Babcock
tattoo give it to it right on your back
all right yeah you want me to make it
real large mmm is that mm yes how long
is Parkman silence okay how long have
you been silenced
oh don't move baby baby it's baby baby
[Music]
no I'm not a dim be I'm not a deadbeat
stop moving
[Music]
then an ingredient there we go
oh dude that's dope can we just can we
just in a skit oh-oh-oh
can we gonna salt I'll just get that big
bag got thank you thank you very much
that's not where he did it I don't know
I didn't babba [ __ ] you're drunk
not gonna are dead
wha it's a I hate all of you good I'm
gonna release you from this the worst I
was gonna release me bro hand tea please
hey my ego my fire
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right no do with my soul
Ty Lee can we just get a close-up on
this just just let them peruse through a
good fit just give a good pan downward
okay
start starting from the top I'll do a
dramatic reading Bobby BB Tyler is dumb
be Ethan it sing damnit not gonna read
what I type I made all of you this is
the worse I can't will ease my ego
Jessie no fuel in my fire please have
mayor eye on my seal rarer node you if
my soul dunked eilean Pabst office I did
whatever you say what were you trying
dunked I leaned back
sometimes a bond sauce oh it was
discussed but uh what is that
well chuffed and cuffed all right I
don't remember that one that means we're
handcuffed Street you and I yep oh we've
already done this
no we're handcuffed okay I think we
should go like this
we're but - but but my hands are tied
behind in front of you so I'm your hands
and then your hands are my hands makes
it you're like yeah that's new it's
gonna work can I do that just tight
around the mills tie it do it Tyler
I gotta put my mic back on what is the
next thing that we're doing what hmm
that's amazing
here we go with your arms up and then do
your waist and I'm gonna go across the
back I can't handcuff you with you your
back the back like or wait I'm
handcuffing on the other side yeah okay
yeah you're handcuffing his hands am i
I'm handcuffing my hands don't worry
about it yeah don't even worry about no
no just the thumbs yet no look we're
fine we got it we don't even need your
tape we can obey by these rules
now we're fine yeah you get your arrow
and you shoot up this is we should get
the the typewriter out of the way I'm
gonna move a lot of stuff this will not
be good it'll be fine it's whoever loses
dies to make sense
where's your safety glasses yeah I don't
know all right
who could do just a few more arrows to
add this one whew
to end it off what's up next something
that's for you to find out what's up
next
soon I don't know what is up next what
is up next I don't oh my god that was on
purpose short short short no please oh
stop okay your turn oh no why no
sideways only fair it's alright that's
oh oh yeah I could have taken those off
a long time ago how is it is a squishy
it's still squishy Audrina is it warm
so no oh very cool so we're getting out
of here for this one but we're not done
yet we're not done at all we've got four
full more hour-long challenges the next
one is I will find out right now
yes blindfold friend yoga this is where
you guys can contribute to what we do we
need suggestions from you for friend
yoga and we're going to be blindfolded
so Tyler and I are gonna be doing it and
Ethan it's gonna try to describe the
pose that we're trying to make and then
we have to do it and we nail it or fail
it based on how we accurately portrayed
but you guys are gonna decide what we're
gonna be doing okay hmm
alright so hashtag bad paw for
everything shut up not tap did test get
them to give them the hold back front
very nice
there it is alright good so when we come
back you've got a lot of time left 30
minutes is a lot of time so please
spread the message about this charity
stream tell people about the next event
that we're gonna be doing get your
suggestions ready for friend yoga get
pictures of poses that two people can do
together so that Tyler and all I can
friend yoga blindfold it and try to
emulate them for you so thank you guys
so much we got a lot more in store we
got
long way to go but we're well on our way
there so keep it moving and we'll see
you at friend yoga in 30 minutes all
right
Siva 3030 don't don't